what is it with sequels they all have to
have a resounding Matrix Reloaded makes
revolutions Resident Evil retribution
Johnny English Reborn why they all have
to have some rethink I don't get it it's
like the new thing I will make you
warrior King how Johnny English Reborn
is a sequel to Johnny English which
stars Rowan Atkinson and we know him as
the voice of Zazu from Lion King and mr.
bean is very talented comic actor I
liked Rowan Atkinson a lot have always
enjoyed things I've seen him in and he
replaced a bumbling British spy who's
called back into action after a
eight-year absence to deal with this
corruption that's going on it has to
find this this evil thing called the
vortex and then there's a mole in the
mi6 or whatever mi7 I don't and he has
to find it sorry for that horrible
horrible description of the plot you
must train hard
make hard what is bad
in the movie we have Gillian Anderson or
Scully from the x-files playing the boss
of all of this organization Rosamund
Pike is in this movie as well I was very
surprised to see that this film is not a
horrible movie I'll just start off by
saying that it's not a terrible movie at
all and Rowan Atkinson is pretty funny
the movie actually it wasn't a bad movie
it really wasn't it's just a very kind
of we've seen it a thousand times before
it really just seems like a slightly
more high-end kind of Disney thing you
know like if Spy Kids 4 was actually
alright it's kind of like that except
it's in no way Wow spike is fourth
bedroom my 7 wants you on the first
flight back to London only then can you
be reborn in English
don't worry you can count on me there's
definitely plenty parts in the movie in
rowan atkinson is a great comedic actor
and he's definitely a very good physical
actor actually the last 20 minutes -
half hour of this movie we're actually
pretty entertaining and it's kind of
what I wanted the rest of the movie to
be like but the build-up to it was
actually kind of boring and it didn't
have like enough consistent humor for me
even though I liked Rowan Atkinson and I
think he's really talented but up until
that ending where it kind of got really
physical with the humor and which is
what Rowan Atkinson really excels at it
was just a lot of you know ball jokes
and things like that and it just it
wasn't very funny rogue states in
Southeast Asia have become secretly to
develop nuclear weapons it is vital that
we get China onside English give me 24
hours
lots of failed physical humor but it's
not a bad movie it's just it's so we've
seen this a thousand different ways you
know it's kind of like Ace Ventura
except without animals it's just a
bumbling guy who thinks he's awesome at
everything is we've seen it before I
think really the reason why I'm not
going to recommend it is just because
there's not enough consistent humor and
up until like the end it's actually kind
of boring I do however like Rowan
Atkinson I like Gillian Anderson and I
like Rosamund Pike there's definitely
talent in this movie it's just that it
seems kind of wasted on this kind of
standard mediocre movie so I'm going to
give Johnny English Reborn a C+
if you liked my review you can subscribe
to my channel and get stuck